because the dehydration reaction is not
observed to occur at 298 kelvin the
student claims that the reaction has an
equilibrium constant less than 1.00
at 298 kelvin
do the thermodynamic data for the
reaction support the student's claim
justify your answer including a
calculation of standard or change in
standard gibbs free energy at 298 kelvin
for the reaction
so let's first of all let's review what
the students claim is the student claims
that since the the reaction is not
observed at 298 kelvin that at that
temperature
the the
the reaction the student claims
that the reaction has an equilibrium
constant less than 1.0 at 298 kelvin
that's their claim and if these idea if
the ideas of equilibrium constant or
gibbs free energy are completely foreign
to you i encourage you to review the
videos on khan academy on gibbs free
energy and equilibrium constants if
they're familiar to you but you're like
okay i don't know all the formulas that
might connect the information that's
given in the problem and how to
calculate delta g and maybe how do we go
from delta g to equilibrium constants
and figuring out whether equilibrium
constant is going to be greater than or
less than one or equal to one the good
thing is is that they they give you all
the formulas that you need it's on the
first page of the free response section
you just have to
understand which ones are applicable and
what's actually going on with those
equations
so let's first of all think about
whether we can
what let's think about whether we can
calculate delta g with the information
that they've given and if you go to the
first page on one of the formulas they
give you and you might even remember on
how to figure out whether a reaction is
spontaneous or not and how you can
calculate delta g based on the
temperature the change in entropy and
the change in enthalpy
the you get
you have this formula right over here
and i literally just copied and pasted
it from what they give you when you take
the test and so they give us the
change in enthalpy for the reaction they
give us the temperature 298 kelvin they
give us the change in entropy for the
reaction this is the change in standard
entropy change in standard enthalpy for
the reaction and so using those we can
figure out what delta g is going to be
and then we can say okay is it
consistent is it is it greater than is
it greater than zero which is consistent
with the reaction not being spontaneous
which seems to be what's observed and
then how can we go from that delta g to
the equilibrium constant well we they
also tell us that delta g is equal to
this second thing and this connects
delta g and the equilibrium constant and
we know some things about rnt in fact we
know exactly what r and t are if we need
them so let's go ahead and and apply
apply these equations right over here
so you have actually let me just write
all the information we have first so
what is
our change in standard enthalpy
we have to figure that out we're going
to have to figure out what our change in
standard entropy is going to be
we know what the temperature is we know
that that is 298 kelvin
and we could worry about r in a second
if if we need to
so up here when they gave us the
reaction they gave us our change in
standard enthalpy and our change in
standard entropy at 298 kelvin this is
very convenient so our change in
enthalpy
is 45.5 kilojoules per mole our change
in standard entropy is 126
joules per kelvin mole so this is very
interesting this is given in kilojoules
this is given in joules and so we want
to make sure that we're being consistent
so let's let's just make sure everything
is in joules so i'm going to write this
this thing is the same thing as 45
500 joules per
mole for this reaction so let me write
this down this is 45 500 this is 126
joules per kelvin mole
so
this is
this right over here
is
45
500
joules
per mole this is 126
joules per kelvin
mole and now we can figure out what the
delta g is going to be the delta g
is going to be equal to well our change
in enthalpy is 45
500
joules
per mole
minus our temperature 298 kelvin
times our change in entropy
times
126
joules
per
per
kelvin
per kelvin mole and notice the kelvin
and then the kelvin those should both be
capital ks
capital k cancel out and the units here
are going to be joules per mole the
units here are going to be joules per
mole and then we just figure out the
difference so let's let's let's do this
let me get my
let me get my calculator out
and so this is going to be
this is going to be let me multiply
these two first you're going to have 298
times
126 is equal to that and let's see i'm
going to subtract this from
thousand five hundred so let me just
make it a negative and add it to forty
five thousand
five
hundred
is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to seven thousand
nine hundred and fifty two and if we
want to stay and we want to stay
consistent with how many significant
digits or significant figures we have
and it looks like it's pretty
consistently three significant figures
so we want three significant figures
here so we could write
7900 roughly seven thousand nine hundred
and fifty
so
our delta g
is approximately seven thousand
nine hundred and fifty
joules per mole and the fact that this
is greater than zero
tells us that this is not going to be
spontaneous at that temperature so it's
already consistent with our observations
and that's always a good reality check
is are the things that you're seeing
consistent what what what the what the
question is describing so delta g
greater than z zero
consistent
consistent
with
reaction
reaction
being
or not being spontaneous
not
being
spontaneous
spontaneous
at
298 kelvin and we in the videos on khan
academy on gibbs free energy we go into
a lot more detail on what this is but
one way to think about it is this is the
energy the change in energy that's
available to do work and so if you have
more if you if your gibbs free energy
increases over the course of the
reaction that means the products have
more energy to do work
and so that means you have to put work
into it in order for the reaction to
actually proceed if your delta g is
negative that means your products have
less energy to do work than your
reactants which means that it can
release that energy and it can do work
and it can be spontaneous so this one
it's greater than zero so it's not going
to be spontaneous but that doesn't
answer the question for us we want to we
want to validate the claim that the
reaction has an equilibrium constant
less than one at 298 kelvin
and lucky for us they also give us a
formula that ties our delta g to our
equilibrium constant and we know the
other things we know r and we know t
and we might not actually even have to
think about them because we don't
they're not even telling us to calculate
the equilibrium constant they're just
saying we'll validate that it's going to
be less than one
and so if we took 7950
joules per
mole is equal to negative rt
times the natural log of our equilibrium
constant we'll solve for the equilibrium
constant let's see if i divide both
sides by negative
rt
negative r t
i'm going to be i'm going to get
the
natural log let me just write it this
way
the natural log
of my equilibrium constant is going to
be equal to
7950
joules per mole
over
negative
negative rt
or you could say
e this is just what power do i raise e
to to get k or so you could say e to the
negative
7
950
joules per mole
over rt is going to be equal to
k
and we could actually calculate what
this is we know which r to use we're
dealing with joules and moles
so it would be this first gas constant
right over here 8.314
joules per mole kelvin
but we actually don't even have to do
that because we just have to validate
that k is going to be less than 1.
what happens if you raise e to a
negative exponent and this is this is
going to be a negative exponent this is
positive
that is positive
this is positive we know it's 298 kelvin
positive
positive
so my entire exponent is going to be
negative so
negative so
negative
so you could say that k
equals e to negative
negative
number
or i could just write
it's kind of weird to write the negative
and then the negative number
e to a
negative
negative number
which must be less than one remember if
if the exponent is zero e to the zero
power is one e to anything positive is
going to be greater than one and e to
anything negative is going to be
less than one let me be careful not less
than zero you actually can't get to less
than zero it's going to be less than
less than 1. and so this by itself
already validates the student's claim if
you want to go further you could just
calculate that you could just say k
is equal to e to the negative 7950
joules per
mole
over
over r which is what 8.314
joules per mole kelvin
8.314
8.314 joules per
mole
kelvin
times 298 kelvin
those cancel out
and joules per mole divided by joules
per mole those cancel out
and so
you would get your number and actually
let's just calculate it just just just
for kicks just to really feel good about
it and you can see this is going to be
dimensionless and equilibrium constants
are dimensionless and so we are going to
get this is a this is kind of fun
so let's see let's let's do this
denominator first if you have
8.314
times 298 times 298
that's going to be equal to that now
we're dividing by that so let me take
the reciprocal of that
and multiply it by 7950 7950
is equal to that now we want to raise e
to the negative of that so let's make
that negative and
now let's raise e to that power so let's
see we can raise e to that power so we
just press that and there you have it
this is approximately 0.440
i guess you could say so this is or four
zero well let's just say four zero four
so this is approximately
approximately 0.404
approximately zero point
i already forgot the number i have a bad
memory 0.0404
0.0404
and the whole rules of significant
figures get a little bit trickier when
you're starting to deal with exponents
like this we're not gonna and they don't
ask us to actually calculate the exact
value but
hopefully this makes you at least
appreciate that the equal equilibrium
constant is for sure is less than one